you can probably tell that during
quarantine i've worked i work out like
crazy
um there's they're actually my assistant
is laughing behind this curtain
um no but i am known
for my uh you know my physicality and my
sensuality and so
i have worked very hard during
quarantine at maintaining
what the public demands from me what
about you or have you
have you worked at it at all are you are
you are you taking care of yourself well
i
i so you and i we answer to the same
masters
um and so your concerns are my concerns
and so i look
from here on down that's the money maker
i'm in form when when you're stuck in
quarantine you've got to you kind of run
out of excuses to give your wife for why
you won't do yoga
with her so um i eventually kind of
caved
taken up snowshoeing snowshoeing
yes so uh um so that's that that's
that's my workout
did you uh are you a skier i'm just
imagining you
you must be a skier you had to be
growing up
so i've gone skiing once i went skiing
once
and snowboarded once uh and never again
each time uh the the skiing the one time
i went skiing was
um with hindsight i suspect it was like
my father's
fumbling attempt to save his marriage
took us all on a ski vacation
um spoiler alert uh my mom
left him two years later and uh
sorry i'm laughing i should say sorry
but what are you gonna do
the marriage broke up and you were
scarred
and there's your impressionable 14
year old robbed of my male role model
and uh but so they they got us all
snowsuits
and we went down to vermont which again
exercising futility because we lived in
montreal don't need to go to vermont to
go
skiing but whatever anyway we went and
and everybody made fun of my snow suit
all the rich american kids laughed at my
snow suit and made jokes about what'd
you get that at walmart and i was like
yeah i think i did actually
and uh and i i gave up after the like
sixth time i ate it
and i was just lying there when i
gear all over the place like a like a
plane crash and my arms at kimbo and
these kids going above me on the gondola
literally laughing like nelson
and uh you know i used to i'm from
boston so my brother and i used to go up
skiing in vermont so i would have been
it's possible i would have been up there
laughing at you
from a gondola you know yeah i realize
the time doesn't exactly lined up i
would probably started my
my showbiz career by then but it's
possible it's possible
that i saw you as like a 12 or 14 year
old
and uh leaned out of a gondola and
laughed at you
because that's the kind of [ __ ] i was
at the very least your spiritual
descendants
uh laughed at me yeah